[Music]
at 1:00 all temper man
[Music]
or one giant special effects budget can
you believe that after 50 years
conspiracy theories about the moon
landing are still in orbit roughly 6% of
Americans believe the moon landing was
faked
while another 5% are undecided what do
you think it would take to pull off such
a hoax how many people would have to
keep quiet and how much would it cost
this is what if and here's what would
need to happen to fake the moon landing
lights camera action July 16th 1969
exterior launch pad Neil Armstrong Buzz
Aldrin and Michael Collins board the
Apollo 11 spacecraft bound for the moon
across the world 600 million people
watched live as the three men are
launched into space land safely on the
moon plant the Stars and Stripes and
make it home safely come to think of it
that does sound a lot like Hollywood but
can you think of a studio with a 150
billion dollar operating budget
in total the Apollo program was
allocated 24 billion dollars to get to
the moon roughly 60% of NASA's budget at
the time that equals a hundred and fifty
billion in today's dollars assuming all
that money went into pulling off the
perfect hoax how would they have spent
it let's start with payroll at the time
NASA had about four hundred and eleven
thousand employees an Oxford physicist
dr. David Grimes calculated that the
secret might have had a chance to stay
quiet for as long as three years and
eight months with that many people so
how do you keep four hundred and eleven
thousand employees quiet about a fake
moon landing mission for longer than
three years
a bribe might be able to buy some
silence today's NASA employees earn an
average of sixty two thousand five
hundred dollars if you divide the Apollo
budget in today's dollars amongst a
workforce of four hundred and eleven
thousand people it comes to a payout of
roughly three hundred and sixty-five
thousand per person of course employees
would have had to accept much less given
the cost of the equipment and the
production needed to fake a moon landing
you may have noticed that the shadows in
the photographs of the moon landing
appear to be parallel image forensics
say these shadows accurately reflect the
sun's position from 93 million miles
away under conventional studio lighting
the shadows would appear more divergent
meaning NASA would have to step up their
game in order to achieve a convincing
look to properly fake the sun's lighting
in the 1960s would require a wall of
millions of powerful laser lights so
close together
they'd be like pixels on a computer
screen now consider that the 150 billion
committed to the Apollo program was
spent on six separate visits to the moon
so whatever the cost of the first
conspiracy bribes equipment etc multiply
that by six in 2009 NASA's Lunar
Reconnaissance Orbiter sent back
high-resolution photographs of each of
the Apollo moon landing sites showing
boot marks left by astronauts to fake
these NASA would have had to send
something to the moon like a robotic
rover to make some tracks the combined
cost of the vehicle and the mission to
put it on the moon would be roughly 68
million dollars then another 504 million
for a lunar orbiter to take the pictures
the bottom line of this prolonged
spending spree is that the cost of
faking a moon landing far outweighs the
cost of doing it for real luckily we're
a species that puts its money where its
mouth is especially when we get curious
and how's your appetite for adventure
are you ready for another one
[Music]